hey soos from Hartford Connecticut
hey social Dave Ramsey show how can we
help how's everybody doing thanks I'm so
glad to be on the show thanks for having
me
absolutely thanks for calling in how can
we help all right so I have been
listening to the Ramsey show for about
three or four years now and so all about
the principles and I pretty much paid
cash for a Nissan Maxima 2006 a couple
years ago and at the point we need some
repairs about 2000 dollars of repairs
like a clutch in a timing chain so I'm
wondering if I invest the money in just
fixing that or I spend about like 10 or
11 grand cash for a newer car I'm torn
I'm not sure my wife and I've been
talking about we just don't really know
what to do so I was like I'll going to
call them see what they think that's
awesome okay have you do you know how
much your car is worth right now it's
got to be worth like thirty five hundred
to four grand because of that thing yeah
and it was very how much money do you
have saved up all in the bank I got
about forty to fifty thousand dollars
cash oh wow that's great well the
wonderful thing is is that you have cash
so obviously you're not going to be you
know you're not asking us to to go get a
brand-new car and take out a loan so I
would say you know any route that has
cash is great so you can always just fix
the front car for two grand driving a
little bit longer save up some more
money and then go get you know a newer
car later or you have cash in the bank I
mean you have 4050 grants if you want to
go get a $10,000 car do you have any
other debt no other deficit is my
mortgage I'm dead I'm dead free besides
my Martin's awesome hey Zeus well Hogan
I don't know I would say definitely that
that you're that you have the cash to go
do either one yeah and I'm on the other
side a little bit where he's definitely
got cash maybe you pay the cash and you
get at Rick's and you drive it a little
bit longer yeah but I mean but here's
the deal having that amount he suits in
the bank
the tendency might be to overspend so I
love the fact that you guys have already
said 11 to 12,000 on a car just be
careful and go in with a game plan
because it's real easy to creep up and
the next thing you know you spent
sixteen or seventeen so don't overbuy we
don't want to have regret we want to
have a good holiday so go into it with
your eyes wide open make sure you and
your wife are on the same page and it
sounds like you guys are moving in the
right direction
so so you would say either
option if I get the blessing from the
Ramsey show well hold on now I don't
know about always easy on the Blasio the
blessing we tricep fix it just yeah hold
on let me ask you this what does your
wife want to do hey Suze oh I know mag
my my wife is sitting here right right
now actually and she you know what she's
not 100% either way too like I honestly
I think she'd rather go with the the
newer car maybe the $10,000 car which he
gets like maybe a 2011 2012 Camry or
something we just want some that's
reliable okay I would say she's waiting
in the other direction okay okay well
that's good I just I'm saying that
because I think being on the same page
is imperative have the blessing from the
wife it's as well my life happy wife
happy life that's what I always lived a
little while I know some stuff well I
tell you right now you gave them the
options you go with what big pop and the
wife say you know I mean Rachel good
stuff all right thanks for the call hey
Suze guys I want to bring up
Christmastime because we have so many
people in this massive tribe the listen
the show every day and they're going for
it
I mean ramen noodles rice and beans
beans and rice you know what I mean just
really sacrificing because they believe
in that finish line they can see it but
this is a tough time of year it's like
excess everywhere in their face and this
is a tough time of year to stay the
course isn't it oh absolutely it is yeah
I mean temptation is everywhere and I
think the expectation of other people
plays a huge part in the Christmas
season from from parents to family to
friends when everyone has their
expectations of what their Christmas
should look like and if you're a part of
that then the expectations on you as
well so I'm a huge believer in that you
have to do its best for you and your
family this Christmas season so if you
are sacrificing your lifestyle you're
getting out of debt
listen people are gonna live they know
they they know that you love them
they're gonna live if they don't get a
Christmas gift from you it's okay
everything's gonna be fine set the
expectation ahead of time and say hey
listen this year we're cutting back
everything because we're won this is our
goal we're going to get out of debt
spread the message tell them what you're
doing and no you don't need any
expectations that you have to get
everyone a gift because in the kids as
well I mean parents go overboard with
Christmas and I want their your kids to
enjoy Christmas I think it's okay to get
them gifts but again it's all about
setting the expectation I mean because
here's the deal a few weeks after
Christmas
those toys or whatever you bought are
going to be sitting somewhere and the
joy of the opening and all of that is
going to have subsided there's a lot of
people out there can that don't have
money things are tight that's right
right now and I would encourage them
that there are things that you can do
that don't require money you can give
the gift of babysitting as a father of
three boys I can tell you that's a gift
oh geez a gift keep on giving right
there you can cook dinner for someone
you can do things take it have an
experience take them out to dinner you
know give them a coupon you know
something like that there are things I
want you to think outside the box and
it's more than just spending money I
think it's about spending time and
especially with parents I think you hit
the nail on the head because parents I'm
telling you Chris Hogan what did you get
for Christmas when you're 10 you don't
miss Stretch Armstrong I think it's mr.
a teacher I took a shot of dark there we
go see no you don't remember what you
got for Christmas as a kid but the
things that I remember our time with my
parents right with the family even we
would go and give and serve as a family
those are memories that are ingrained in
my mind so so do things that are gonna
live beyond the Christmas season again
it's okay to get your kids some gifts
listen little Amelia you better believe
she's get a baby doll or two you better
believe she is yes because I love her I
want to get her some Christmas gifts but
what's important is that time with your
family and that's what your kids are
gonna remember it's so true we get so
caught up and all the stuff and the fact
is when we sacrifice now and then we get
to that freedom space it's going to make
these seasons of life where you really
did suffer and you go boy there's so
much sweeter now that I can do a holiday
debt-free haven't worked with people
that have worked hard and busted in and
stayed focused and built wealth those
people are giving gifts now because
they're able to and they're able to do
it with a good heart and the right
mentality and so for those out there
that are pushing and trying to drive
forward stay focused keep your eye on
the prize don't let your guard down
because there's people out there to have
a plan for your money if you don't so
you need to make sure you have a plan
and you stick to it you know Rachel you
talk about this stuff all the time but I
have found that when Stacey and I have
been intentional with the kids and
teaching them you know the importance of
the Christmas season and it's not about
stuff that we actually get better in the
course of teaching them what it's really
about absolutely because you're having
to live out what you're teaching right
and then it suddenly changes you
yeah 100% so I love that just the
encouragement to you all out there to
stay the course changing your family
tree is so much bigger than than just
Christmas this year right I mean it's
right so so look far beyond sometimes
you just make the short-term sacrifices
for the long term game but it's worth it
and just serve somebody if nothing else
just go love as Chris said on somebody
and watch their reaction and then you'll
realize how huge of a gift that really
is because we get so hung up and all the
stuff we get and to your point since my
boys open up the presents they're on to
the next one and I'm over there building
Lego stuff that I don't even like to
build isn't that so true no honestly I
have the attention span you know of a
squirrel on some type of narcotics so I
can't stick with the Legos you know to
me it's just too much well I think Legos
are like a home defense system have you
ever stepped on one in bad boys in the
middle of the night
listen just beyond me and my sister
Millie Amelia's still crawling around do
you step on one of her toys see how
spiritual goes that hurts
oh man fun stuff you guys would be so
rich so fast and be able to do so much
not only for yourselves and for your
family but for others
oh we're dead